hey i'm honored to be here
with bruce tim legendary writer artist
animator with
warner brothers he's known for many cool
accomplishments
most notably his massive contribution to
the creation of the modern dc animated
universe
and of course probably his finest work
the flaming
sea i was just improvising and you
created that character on the spot
that gave me the idea what if we went
out in an rv
and we just picked up some random people
could we
turn them into iconic
comic book superheroes i guess we'll
find out i guess we will find out
because we did rent the rv you're paying
for it
[Music]
jerry good to see you come on in this is
my friend bruce tim
just answer a couple of questions and
we'll create a superhero around you
good luck as a child were you ever
bitten by a radioactive spider or bug
i remember it very well it crawled in my
ear it was a box elder bug
a box elder bug i lived in elder trees
what if
like ant-man ant-man can control ants
yeah what if he can control
other elder bugs so that you have the
ability
to say elder bugs unite and elder bugs
come from all the elder trees
and if you can get a hundred thousand of
them together you can steal a ritz
cracker
who's your arch enemy who do you not
like in real life tell me some of your
pet peeves i don't know if it's stupid
people so much it's just that
it's the time we live in now the uh
you know it's a kind of a dumbing down
of the whole culture
do you realize what show you're on right
now what else what other pet peeves like
specific things
i can't stand asparagus you don't like
asparagus
for me your enemy is asparago
asparago can shoot you with a beam and
your urine has an odor
for 40 minutes that's what we got so far
that is you rocketing along
on this three-wheeled craft and where
and the bug is where
it's sticking out of his ear there it is
right there i like this
[Applause]
do you have any thoughts about what kind
of hero you would be i want to be one of
those
everyday save the day kind of guys
i want to be the right on red guy
captain right on the red because every
time i get to a stop sign
or stop light it's like right go right
here come on drive like
on drive so this is a great origin story
you were from new york
okay then you moved to los angeles where
people are slow
maybe it's the power to speed things up
but get out of my way array get out of
my ear
look at that anger coming through it's
okay
let it out this is we're here to help
you lose the smile make him angry yeah
he's angry
he's angry this guy i'm an angry
superhero
but you know what a lot of them are true
do we need a name oh yeah what's your
name
rap rat rapid rick
rip rick rapping rick rapid what do you
have what do you do for a living yeah
that's hot
that's okay you're just having a small
heart attack is this a weakness if you
were to think
he sweats profusely all right what about
a vehicle what kind of vehicle would you
want
batman is the batmobile i could have the
black mobile
what was it that screw the black mobile
to us i
see like a like a bike a bike
what are your interests what are your
hobbies i love art you love art a big
hard guy
okay maybe instead of wheels there's a
uh
modernist painting where the wheels
would be yeah
you are riding
and uh you are enraged though
well what if he's like one of those
oddball superheroes that's like
he's just like all head and beard no
body
floating yeah the floaty head yeah
headbeard
no body that's interesting you're just a
head that floats with a beard
you know what you might be a villain
maybe it might be available
because you have no body it enrages you
and that turned you evil is that
possible i i'm pretty negative
yeah you're a negative guy and you know
what he travels on a cloud of negativity
ah where are you from
uh florida originally oh my god which is
when you were in florida you said you
wanted to try and catch a gator how do
you
catch a gator with that beard one
chump and he's got you for him to be
like eating pasta hit chump on the beard
and then
and then i've got him it tastes like
you've got him you're in his belly dude
i've got him i've got you now gator i'm
inside you
being digested but then i come out yeah
this is claw my
feces with a hat on it
okay how many times today have men tried
to lure you into a
uh van are you from i'm originally from
vegas are you from vegas which is weird
i know
okay no one's from there no one's trying
people just go there to die
do you have the same aversion to the sun
that i have i
burst into flames how about this your
superhero character
must avoid the sun at all costs yeah
you must live in perpetual night so you
can't come out during the daytime
that sounds like most people from las
vegas
are you a good athlete i do hot yoga and
you're sweating a lot when you do that
would i be able to come with you
sometime when you do that absolutely
really yeah what if i'm just in the
corner watching you and i'm not
participating
and maybe recording it maybe
you had me until recordings um i just
said that she's topless at the moment so
we need we need we need
is she tapless in that well just because
we haven't come up with what the the top
looks like those are
her breasts and they're not covered we
won't look at them what would you like
to wear i didn't say don't
now that it's there we have to deal with
it we gotta change the shape
i gotta change this kind of boost tell
me what kind of boobs you want um
just like here what hi
you can have whatever breasts you want
this is los angeles
oh yeah what's your name well people
call me doris mayday
payday yeah mayday this is terrific
you're protected by your yoga mat you
have your
vintage stuff
[Applause]
here she is ready to start her new life
as a superhero mayday
[Applause]
you look fantastic hi how you doing
we'll take a break ladies and gentlemen
we'll be right back curtis 50 cent
jackson's here
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see
even more great conan clips you may now
return to your pirated movies
and creepy japanese pornography